everybody walking a stream KOCO a
beautiful go Paul yay I want everyone to
see my awesome ramen shirt beef
there we go what's your flavor flavor of
Robin chicken or beef hey guys hey Kevin
hey FERC for life hey Johnny J whacker
What's Up boo clouds how we doing
blastin zombies 203 I shaved it's
terrible sorry apologies I'm trying to
desperately grow it back before the
streets yeah I might just like you know
do like one of these maybe I should do
this here's what I said where I think I
should wear a glove and then just talk
through my like this is it terrible
everybody is a terrible glue it back on
I tried turbo Dave I tried
today we're gonna be playing one of my
favorite games and I've been playing in
my real life on my own my own stuff
which is Mario Odyssey it's great super
fun Kevin played this game what are you
doing with your life I'll tell you
you're wasting it that's what you're
doing there you go yeah that's a way
better positive spin on things there we
go
all right let's get into it I basically
have I'm about halfway through the game
as the kids say why would the kids say
that I don't know smoking some weed man
we see those eyes brah uh you know what
I haven't I've had a lot of carbs today
maybe that's it people have like their
face just gravitates towards your eyes
yeah yeah I think that's what is this
probably never I've seen your eyes
before right oh Jesus oh no oh God
I fell in the water uh yeah I think
they've never seen my eyes the whites of
my eyes sorry by Nature Jesus says Jesus
Christ no beard lame right uh you la
guys find the most disturbing clothing
9ul a gun don't blame all of la just
blame me cuz it's my fault
if you haven't heard of Mario Odyssey
a.k you've been living under a frickin
rock
the idea here is you are Mario and you
have your hat is askew of a sentient hat
you can kind of throw it you see what
I'm doing here that's why my hat also
has eyeballs on it which is creepy
so it's a terrible game for paranoia
paranoia acts retro gamer and wise has
gift me a free switch in the game and
I'll run around my neighborhood yelling
that Conan is a comedy god how about you
do that first then we'll decide so
basically you could throw your hat and
your hats is sentient so what happens is
Bowser because you know Bowser is a dick
as we all know or just severely
misunderstood he basically stole he
stole the princess as he's want to do
and he also stole when he stole the
princess he stole
oh there's things dropping he stole
capi that's our caps name
he stole copies girlfriend or sister I
don't know the exact story but anyway so
we got to get so there's a lot and
there's a lot on the line here there's a
lot investing and when you throw your
hat you actually get to capture things
you become that thing so for some
animals see that's our hat talking to us
it looks like a giant goes to I don't
know what's going on girlfriend's sister
what yeah yeah he's basically odd-job
held Helen what does Coco stand for why
not team Conan that's a good question
because back we were The Tonight Show
Tom Hanks gave Conan the nickname Coco
and then when that ended we became Team
Coco because there was it was like the
time of Twilight and so it was like Team
Jacob 2009 there was like Team Jacob and
Team Edward and so he became Team Coco
that's kinda what happened yeah that's
more fun to say Coco than it is to say
Conan right oh jeez this is basically a
dune inspired level these are like giant
sand worms kind of you know or maybe
like beetlejuice inspired level fun so
you gotta use these things to your
advantage man not for the faint of heart
I got to say lieutenant's done a great
job at this game it's super fun there's
a ton of like ingenuity involved and
imagination as in all or most Nintendo
games I should say but this one in
particular feels like pretty inspired
which is great I think there's a lot of
hype about this game go hat go and it
looks like and when you jiggled it I
don't want to do it down here because
that's for us but it's like if you
jiggle it more then it becomes like a
homing hat which is kind of cool
ah damn all about timing man yeah
shouldn't you be doing a show Judge Judy
they're gonna be clueless camera in this
I don't know good question I would like
there to be but who knows yeah Andy I
hey thanks invader I got my beef on
today wearing some and you know what it
smells like beef doesn't it just a
little bit that's just my natural odor
yeah it happens whenever I'm wearing
anything life lesson always wear a hat
that's right Darth butters attorney
hidden anything over here any hidden
stuff no nothing I jump up on here
anyway
oh wait what's this about hold on one
second there we go
you know what Mario is great grip
strength yeah a lot of upper-body
strength
dude works out man for a plumber extra
moon so basically we are pursuing Bowser
across this world and we have to get
these moons which seems dumb the moon is
kind of dumb we got to get these moons
to power our spaceship business
spaceship or whatever art it's in the
shape of a giant hat I mean it tend to
win all in on their father the Balder
dad
what's up burns e16 how you doing who in
the chat has finished this game is my
question
you're a flat moving earth okay you
think the moon is flat fair enough
Saverio town named after somebody got
shipped I'm guessing you variate a Mario
a known Ninja Warrior that's to where a
widow need you where
you know I gotta say guys I know a lot
of the country is facing a you know snow
and winter get yourself one of these
hats look how well this clears the snow
you know we were in New York now for a
week of shows we did a week of shows you
Paula uh and it didn't snow but it had
cold rain the entire time I'd rather
have snowman nose and snow for the wind
what's going on here a lot of tall snow
also if you do how do you play this game
in the controller probably not very well
cuz you can like throw your thing up you
do like this kind of not really fair
enough yeah boobie dude do a close
camera Childress Lansky now Jordan
doesn't like games unless you're talking
about mind games or mobile games there
you go mind your mobile but not in
mobile non mind
[Music]
wait a second what's this over here
this is a hidden moon such Oh God Oh No
go hidden moon situation anybody moon
moon I'm so spoiled any hidden thing I'm
hoping as a yes
got to get them moons the purple chords
your loose change
haha perfect what I need is a game
reviewing coffee yeah no kidding he
would he would do that or wine also it's
really just like yelps the game yeah
exactly
whether or not he would agree or
disagree with Yelp reviews is the game
renewed Jordan uh-oh I'm sensing a boss
battle everybody oh yeah they're these
a-holes oh look it's the a whole Patrol
you go Blair love your game reviews hey
thanks mattes I love your comments which
game you like more Odyssey amaura ask
your brother while Mario Odyssey
I've never been a huge I respect breath
of the wild for sure I respect it I
think it's amazing I've never been a
huge Elda fan and I thought this guy
once before Jesus
the old Neil blooper reel yeah
give me them coins jeez it's a hat fight
good old-fashioned hat fight and oh I
missed it Sammy
brother give me on this thing
dami the student dammit like a rabid
version of the killer clowns from outer
space I have no idea of your type awful
toys
Conan would be roasting everything he's
roasting everything I say from his uh
from his office basically explain the
ugly jacket I don't know what you're
talking about because I'm wearing a
beautiful beef themed jacket and it's
not a jacket it's a sweatshirt
Jesus open your eyes come on Reggie
we I wish I could do that in real life
I'm sure you could do anything any of
this stuff in real life all right let's
put the hurtin on this fool are you
playing something cool like Battlefield
uh well battlefields cool
that's true but so is Mario Odyssey this
game is really fun
ramen powers many college students
exactly I'm wearing basically a every
college kid watching us just is seen
just fuel oh damn it well oh yes here
yeah I mean oh god I can't tie my cool
falls
if you get a good sense of there we go
wait for me dude get off my jockey Oh
what does this hat made of by the way
[Music]
I'm sorry this is the easiest bosses
yeah exactly the movie killer comes to
our space yeah I've seen it why are you
guys talking about killer Colorado
spaces the better question I'm very
excited for today's show
guys we have Josh Hutcherson on the show
PETA amazing super funny met him at
comic-con a few years back really great
guy
hope he brings a little overbred that's
right to fall in love with that and and
we have dahveed what's his name Debbie
Diggs for Hamilton on very exciting
that's right very cool we also have an
amazing musical guest on today Talib
Kweli featuring anderson pack or
anderson pack featuring Talib Kweli I'm
not sure who is featuring who but oh my
god I'm getting railed by this guy dude
oh my god this is embarrassing
hi guys I swear about this bad - time
Jesus horrifying I'm sorry I have played
but I've not played well battlefront 2
Star Wars Battlefront 2 I haven't played
it a lot of people are upset about those
loot boxes though people are really
upset with the way ea
handled the rollout of battlefront 2 and
some of the things in the game they're
very pissed about it I haven't played it
I hear Darth Maul is awesome
what's that one thing that's interesting
that I didn't really think about before
I played the first Star Wars Battlefront
was how visceral sound effects can be
like the TIE fighters like the sound of
a TIE fighter takes me back to when I
was a kid it's just crazy fighting in
the rebellion cool I already lost a
heart just right off the bat
see the problem is my hat is going for
the is greedy it's going for the coins
oh Jesus
good god man
oh I'm the worst I'm not doing good fan
of relatability I'm sorry ain't nobody
got time does totally bad swears he's
not bad seems legit
I am terrible I know baby fit I know
Madeline babyface babyface play or Blade
II face which is what no one's called me
but I'm hoping somebody will no one's
called guys I'm disappointed I'm
disappointed in the chat that no one
came up with blady face I had to come up
with that myself I'm just a beefy blady
face today guys that's all I have now
the holidays are upon us
what's every what's one of the games
that everybody's looking forward to
asking for I personally Oh God
right off the bat oh my god we'll just
give it up Blair I suck at this I swear
no I'm not normally this bad I guess I
am normally this bad because I'm this
bad
it's not the you know what stop training
make excuses drive for bid for
performance I didn't like how someone of
the chat was just like this is the
easiest boss you ass yeah exactly
oh boy any in all games this is not the
first level surly done
buddhu VR oh how Skyrim VR hell's its
guy Romero be great do VR be really fun
we should check that out I said I mean I
guess it's pathetic
or it's uh yeah Bethesda right man doom
was like such an intense game the new
doom I really loved we did a clueless
camera with that and that was just like
so fun just absolutely bananas all right
come on you dicks don't face or run away
we use attack and use your hat to
protect yourself okay fallout for VR
damn we believe in you blade thank you
Anastasia asking this game on a switch
the switch has been great I eat the
rabbit
I'm trying bro I gotta say I've been
traveling a lot lately and the switch
has been really fun way more fun than I
thought God get off me bro
go on Jesus Christ
here he comes
[Music]
yeah you see me curl up into a
protective ball oh god yes Homer I read
all the comments and he spelled Homer
wrong there's no you and Homer there's
no all right here we go
does anybody have does anybody have any
tips for this guy come on man just run
somebody else was saying don't run use
your hat all right wait what is that
would you say I'll run in circles when
he hops all right partner
all right skip it Oh fair enough
I'm really having more trouble just
hitting him on the head I think is part
of the problem oh dude the circles thing
is working whoever said the circles
saying you're the best oh Jesus
all right
all right got him twice all right
circles run in circles here we go let's
go
circles I'm sure there's some kind of
like physics question involved with this
oh is this gonna be too far away those
the question too far away
I know bort my frickin hat
there's a freaking heart here in that
heart
double boom so why is he like looking
around like that alright here we go here
we go
second form second form oh no we died
that was it
oh no I feel like a real ass I thought
that was like gonna be like three stages
[Music]
you know makes you feel so good about
doing like yeah makes you feel so good
about doing that stuff it's awesome may
the force be with you wrong game exactly
Zack there we go where is basically
circle strafing old school all right now
what there's like a race or something
now I gotta go down this deep dark hole
into the pit it would be really funny I
know Nintendo would never do this but it
would be really funny to just at one
point have something with like a ton of
blood this is like somebody's head gets
ripped off and it's only like one quick
point in the game you know and then like
we didn't see that you're like I'm like
a cutscene they do it's super fast yeah
it's like and it's like horrifying and
someone's arm gets ripped off and then
like it's never commented on again and
everyone it's like wait WTF it's no line
circuit yeah here we go
what's up started Debbie yeah dude we're
all waiting to start this race no but
Robin
hit me up I'm starting a cooking show on
Friday on my channel twitch.tv slash
Turner Blair so yeah that's gonna be you
want to see my kitchen TuneIn gonna be
awful do I go in here yeah yeah I do
I'm gonna make I'm trying gonna try to
make oh whoops
so my cooking show tomorrow night I'm
gonna try to make something that's never
been made before Pizza roll hot dogs I
love hot dogs I love pizza rolls it's
trying to make a pizza roll hot dog
whenever you're about to ask me I don't
know the what but go ahead ask
the hotdogs gonna be inside of no I
think the idea is to make a hot dog out
of pizza rolls oh you never go to
7-eleven and they have the yeah it's
just like a brand with like some bread
I'm gonna try to take pizza rolls and
mash them up and then what do you mean
that's what goes on your stomach oh I'm
sorry do you like stuff plated properly
or you only eat things that are
aesthetically pleasing yeah okay fair
enough
hey there's a cat is mayonnaise an
instrument can be it's crazy the voice
of Mario also voiced o Partha necks and
Skyrim really that's pretty cool I met
that guy it like an e3 thing alright
what's up I got to find another racer
okay how about you wait what was your
idea oh that's stupid
Oh or to mush up a hot dog and put it
inside a roll that well that's also
possible that's also possible oh hey
buddy you scared oops didn't mean to
step on you hey pal what's the big deal
also how can those short arms reach the
top of your head that seems impossible
don't forget to share your pizza don't
worry goon or it's me Frodo didn't know
what to do here took me ten minutes or
so to start the race GMC revolution so
what do I do
anybody know how to start this race best
police eat ramen in LA you know
ironically I don't really eat ramen like
ramen
oh there you Beth knows well actually
there's probably a lot more that was
good am i basically just doing the race
by myself it's kind of listen Mario it
looks like a badass me like slides down
the wall like that
so Jason Bourne throw my hat at him oh I
gotta go throw my hat at him okay thanks
guys how cute is this little snow suit
I'm wearing by the way leave this guy
mario guy cqt you know i tried to
actually grow a mustache like mario and
it looked I looked like bad real bad
like John Candy is like a Chicago cop
yeah here we go Oh baby see I told you
that's my new catchphrase guys you guys
ever have a weird thing where you start
saying like a phrase or word all the
time dope I'm ready
let's do it
anyway I started saying ooh baby and I
said it yesterday when I came out of the
bathroom it wasn't a great idea ooh baby
it's someone's like what what happened
in there
Justin tomato tomahto
god I feel like Sonic is watching with
copyright lawyers yeah exactly
if there's a loop-de-loop and like a
word there's definitely gonna be it
Rossi here we go all right let's go no
I'm terrible at this what is that little
thing oh I see - teach me
it's pretty dope cuz we're drifting can
I drift how long is this training gonna
go on yeah I think we are - dude oh quit
training yeah I should just done that at
me yeah thank you poppy
Blair you should do a game review that's
Lansky man can even imagine I can he's
terrible at games and hates things holy
crap are you get this hoodie ah Google
they also have ones that say chicken
also you know they have ones they have
pants F why does it look shiny bounding
- god these guys are killing me
I guess the name of the game is bounding
here oh jeez oh this is I'm doing real
bad
is that right everyone just balanced huh
I was going faster I was just rolling
cool
I'm doing real bad guys I'm so sorry
I'm six is that good or bad can I just
go across this way nope oh it doesn't
let me
I can't cheat can't cheat
someone said maybe you should've prayed
harder
shut up Chad I'm doing my best I just
bow oh my god who's ready to watch 20
minutes of me failing at this Oh God
all right you know what I think hey I
got the best score though the best time
new record I'm so sad okay okay they
also have ramen pants but the problem is
what it should be is if you see this the
pants should just be the beef yeah it'd
just be beef all the way down instead it
just it's the same pattern it just says
rot so it sucks so don't get the pants
but this is and it's also extremely warm
guys I mean I need to get into character
it went from Mortal Kombat to Super
Monkey Ball real quick Mario Cart bounce
edition here we go okay I'm ready here
we go let's do it bound now I kind of
got the hang of it I'm gonna be in the
mix
I think that's that's a little shortcut
we can take
I'll shite
it's three it's three laughs pet
Oh No
oh no I don't have a neck how can it be
neck and neck there's no next year
it's like blob and blob man damn it
retro gamer analyzes by the way you
nailed this every stream is Aaron's new
outfit he struggles with games Beth
minecraft bet this total you know she's
Mike she's Bitcoin she's mining for
bitcoins we don't pay her so this is a
way though
yeah sorry yes be the ball I'm trying
I'm trying surly duck here we go sorry
sorry sorry lame I know I know I'm a
loser okay here we go
let's go let's go let's go I'm ready is
there a way for me to play dirty in this
I can't get caught up in the mud
there we go
I think just little bounces are the way
to position yourself properly you know
let's go let's gun dammit
oh man green is so far ahead
bad bounce they call me the streets bad
bounce
is this is this how many laps is this I
gotta catch up to this dude that's right
that's where I can improve in the cut
boom there we go there we go
gotcha yeah I never been to the streets
well Marriott er I Drive on the streets
I Drive on streets
well supersonic snowing alright alright
thank you give me that multi moon mini
yeah oh that's sweet sweet multi moon
boom well cleats I think we're about to
go on to a new oh man so great alright I
think we're about to go into new new
world here I think we're pretty close
look at that hat head hang it he's got
terrible hot head ever farted in a jar
and open two years later no you mean
like a fart time capsule no I never have
uh but I wonder that actually does big a
good question if you did that what it's
still stink I still smell I think it's
like bacteria right that makes it I
don't honestly I don't know this is a
question for reddit yeah go to this the
fart subreddit and ask that question get
back thank you
yeah exactly for work maybe if someone's
gonna do it I farted in a jar years ago
and opened an AMA yeah yeah that's also
a possibility how much that sweatshirt
I'm gonna say a good twenty dollars on
to the luncheon Kingdom ooh this is the
perfect Kingdom for us because we're
about that once look it's like a giant
hat I don't know how I feel about this
whole thing
they really double down on the hats yeah
we could skip the movie we don't care
well Mythbusters tried at Jeff Smith
what did they say they're scheduled as a
stream says Ryan ah they're normally on
Wednesdays at noon this week we had to
change it a bit because we had crazy
meetings that's right power means every
single one I will Jojo but not not in
this dream frosted cake the wedding
don't care bla bla bla don't care you
know I gotta say Nintendo not great on
the story so he's kind of the same every
time when Nintendo does
great in game played a lacking story but
that's okay there's a shitty ask science
reddit that would probably like that
question do it marry otter who this is a
very oh we're gonna be way too hot Wow
now this is amazing
the brutal czar after some cooking seems
like they could have shortened that
title you know you smell what the brutal
Tsar cooking might have been a better
now work we're just we're way too hot
man alright I'm sorry I need to get back
in my yeah we got to change her outfit
like this is gonna be way too hot for us
the luncheon Kingdom
oh we're gonna overheat we got to change
our really now it's pretty hot I think
we just go boxers let's go straight
boxers boxers on the bottom yeah and
then what do we want on top Fedora
pirate hat like a naughty pirate oh this
is kind of fun a Sun Hat what do you
think
oh yes swimming trunks I know what do
you like what do you guys think uh
Osmond I don't know ganush I'm not sure
pirate hat marry otter says I heard hat
ramen noodle top we don't have that here
yeah all I'm seeing is pirate hat
captain's hat Sun Hat player I'm seeing
two pirates two suns resort hat with the
resort hat straw hat alright I'm seeing
a lot of straw hats let's do it yeah
yeah baby whoo got to be comfortable I
cannot wait for when he gets a ramen top
I'm very excited or just something that
that's beef ask all right we're ready to
roll
this one I think flight flies a little
bit better you know I can't get me can't
get me kid get me damn it
here we go
this game is so fun you got what the
hell oh damn
Oh killed on my dude y'all man do I get
to be a girl cheese do I get to be a
girl cheese at some point
[Music]
this is look at this giant corncob this
is the worst thing to play right before
we're gonna eat lunch I'm so hungry
what's happening here Oh God oh lordy
holy Moses oh god oh no oh my god this
is crazy
donkey is the master of the goombahs do
donkey is amazing
I love donkey can we put uh I mean he
doesn't need the traffic can we put a
link to video game donkeys a YouTube
channel I do he's my favorite I want to
have him on the stream at some point
would it be great if we had donkey on
here guys donkeys the best video game
donkey he's the only video game reviewer
i watch he's the greatest
dude he's hilarious
[Music]
you do it all right what have you got
there somebody we can like float around
in like all this sauce what is this like
bubblegum what kind of sauce we talking
pink pink hot oil bubbling pink oh
brother
got a Lima Bean over here oh Jesus these
things can roll I can't roll up the does
it stay there forever I just screw
myself there's got to be some it does
stay there forever doesn't it sighs I
think I just got it yeah I need to just
own it I think and just keep running
oh this cute little hat whoa what was
that
what up in there well they hid in the
pile of salt what's happening here pick
it up there that way I gotta be a bunch
of oh my god I got to get all the
mushrooms
I gotta have you all the goombas whoo
and less oh I see you oh you know what I
think that hat might allow me to go
through the wall stack the goombas and
visit the female Goomba oh my god I got
this sucks you have to woo the lady
Goomba
I'm terrible with girls though guys
goombahs or humans all right I knew the
goombas are gonna be involved damn is
goombahs all right oh I can - with these
guys oh my god all right what do you
think a Goomba sounds like like if they
were to have like a human voice
I just keep thinking about Lee oh my god
this is gonna be ridiculous
oh god this sucks this sucks this sucks
hi hi oh there we go oh I see it's a
means to an end here all right
it's me ha ha
Goomba mass-transit I guess I just keep
being the Goomba right so what happens
now
I guess I got to go this other way it's
actually easier to the Goomba it's
actually easier to run as the Goomba Oh
take that back what's happening over
here
oh you know what I bet I could be that
guy and then swim around don't you think
yeah oh this is great this is so fun man
guys this game is dope it's great look
at this
can I go up on land what happens if I go
on land Oh God nervous up tomato
it's funny wouldn't a strikeout just be
burnt up by this thing I've ever played
Dark Souls I have I hate Dark Souls it's
really frustrating
the female Goomba wanted for Goomba
wanted for suitors to pick between yes
that question is don't you just become
one Goomba I don't know that's a
metaphysical question our for Goomba is
too far gumbaz become one
that's guy's a jerk Wow I hate this guy
boom here we go
stay away from me dude stay in your lane
stay in your lane
[Music]
stay in your lane
number two steak get great and son of
[ __ ]
[Music]
whoa check out of Kona nest care I do
got a white collar wouldn't be great if
Conan grew long hair oh my god long red
hair but he still kept his pop you
bought the same jacket the lady has
y'all friends yeah bunny all puking
Exorcist style yeah it was very Exorcist
inspired like what come under the cheese
rocks cheese rocks are not a thing I
want to see cheese rocks gross I don't
eat it oh wow so that was interesting
the boss started the level that was kind
of cool nothing cool uh-oh
can I be mr. Fork you bet your butt I
can you the flag's let you teleport by
the way love just kind of fun
cheese rocks yay whoo oh my god I'm so
hungry right now
can I jump in there am I gonna get hurt
what do you think let's try it it's
probably bad idea yep that's a really
bad idea Beth you're right let's see
what we can get let's see we can buy
your I'm covered in sick oh my god that
seems cheese rocks and saltine cracker
tree bark you know it works her people
dude it's what kind of cool stuff we got
oh oh we got a chef of course we got the
shield chef's hat
or where the chefs at for now oh man oh
wait we also got oh cool like apron over
there
Wow there's a lot of cool stuff here on
a painter I don't care about the
painters do we let me care more about
being a chef we're The Naked Chef guys
this thing I feel like this is not gonna
fly very well this hat you know that one
thing they could have done I will say
and made but maybe it's too insane for
Nintendo too deep is it would have been
cool to have different hats that do
different things you know like different
kind of weapons
you know weaponize the Hat a bit instead
of every hat just being the same thing
and it being kind of a gimmick it would
be kind of it would be another level if
you could like do different things with
a hat jumped up there
[Music]
I got skills man I like the Beast and
split crawling walls I don't know why I
went there
yeah
Conan doesn't let us eat unless we earn
our pay my slacking off no way I didn't
dude let me up up here dude
beans
it's just fun I like the music the music
is always great gotta run around explore
look ooh fun hmm
oh I see some things over here
it is I do have to kind of be careful in
these games because I get weirdly
obsessed with like getting every single
moon or every single whatever this is
purple
apple grapes thing
[Music]
whoo three clues gamers The Witcher 3
when I die every time I watch it
well don't watch it you're gonna die our
stew will be ruined all right I got to
figure out the stew situation by the way
speaking of stew I just saw what we do
in the shadows really funny that's a
great movie you guys should all see if
you like if you're a fan of Flight of
the Conchords and who isn't it's awesome
it's about it's a mockumentary about
vampires and it stars my new favorite
crush how do you say his name like go
what team tight how you what is it Tyco
YTD did the director of thor ragnarok
and he was also oh yeah I think so yeah
in wanna know oh yeah yeah in moaña he's
also somebody oh geez
he's the crap I think more it's an
amazing movie it's on Amazon Prime video
for free yes it is it's so good it's
really really funny the beast guys the
beast but there's a guy named stewing it
and that's why I thought it because stew
is becomes their friend and he's soft
pile out
what's over here I do love exploring
guys great game by baby do way too
easily yeah it's true so wait a second
here's something for the chat how do I
break what is the deal with these and
how do I break them anybody know what do
I do with these the Beast I know Mary
Ann right rock was cool then Roz Samuel
Amanda oh yeah yeah are you in the
shadows
Darth what we do in the shadows so what
what do I do here anybody have any idea
can I open this on my own or is this
something I have to come back to oh I
see
I can't do it until I beat this story
hey Erin I challenge you to hug that
babe says mr. meatballs challenge denied
she didn't Beth doesn't want me to hug
her yeah
you must be pure of heart to open that
Oh
post-game all right Branagh
oh those are the challenge levels I see
okay I thought I was missing out guys
you know I don't miss out of this game
out of all the things you can become I
think the dinosaur was the coolest bye
heard you never get to be the dinosaur
again you only get to be the dinosaur in
the very beginning and that's it ooh
with some hidden coins up in this birch
cool just died that was cool
awesome that was really fun I'm glad I
did that will you be my one up girl what
does that mean hot burgers and first of
all I'm not a woman but thank you I know
the beard doesn't really make it clear
anymore I'm not a woman but I'm not no
so yeah it's like a New Zealand
Nosferatu it's really good highly highly
recommend we do the shadows well well
well what do we have here
favorite Nintendo character whoa I love
me some Kirby I mean I guess I gotta go
I look Luigi's I feel like he never
really gets his due you know it's always
Mario I just died you're Marco whoo all
right keys great dad starts the Mushroom
Kingdom lock like look like real little
middle children love Luigi I'm an oldest
child as what does that say I've just
I've just defeated your reasoning
[Music]
oh this is crazy
I see
[Music]
oh Jesus don't fall off the frickin edge
bro there we go oh that was dumb it's
tough to take me seriously in a ramen
hooding without pants well you shouldn't
take me seriously period I think that's
what we're learning for this oh Jesus
sliding down to my death just slowly
sliding down to my death
damn it well guys it's 1 o'clock which
means the stream is over thank you all
for joining us this was super fun we
will see you next week on Wednesday at
noon tune in tomorrow night to twitch TV
data and blurt if you want to see me try
to make I'm gonna try to make a pizza
roll hot dog it's my new cooking show
it's gonna be awful uh Robin hoodie
available online just Google Robin
hoodie please watch the show tonight we
have the amazing Josh Hutcherson on as
well as dahveed how you saved last night
Debbie Diggs how do you say his last
name the V takes from Hamilton and of
course telling kweli and Anderson Park
is gonna be amazing thank you all for
joining us we'll see you guys next week
see you later bye
you